proprio la giornata giusta per perdere
un po di anni di vita
siamo ritornati ragazzi su paranormal hk
in un momento topico del gioco molto
carino molto bello che mi ricorda quanto
mi piace a fare lo youtube mi piace
veramente un sacco fare lui youtuber e
proprio lavoro che sognavo ma è scusata
segnato nella porta che c'è qui a
sinistra ci arrivo non ci arrivo quindi
non ci andiamo bastato fresco demonio
non c'è una finestra la quale posso
uscire
porca vacca veloce e picchia ragazzi
allora è impossibile non si può fare
questa pareva ok qui senza ragazzi un pò
1 sfigatello nel non riuscirci però vi
giuro che è veramente difficile
non so dove dovrei andare spiega mi qual
è il punto
adesso vado avanti anche se tipo va
avanti procida sinistra vediamo perché
non c'è modo marco demanio ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta così aiuto che tratta
giorgio aprì la donna moderato di caffè
non lo so però continua anno si chiuse
la porta a posto a posto tutto giusto
tanto qua attorno nel corridoio come se
niente fosse
sono tornato nel corridoio di prima non
è a posto ragazzi ma vediamo se c'è una
porta che si apre qui oggi solo questa
qua ci sono questo meno male che è
sempre giorno fuori comunque almeno
quello c'è qualcosa allora storie media
poi c'è qualcos'altro qui carpi with
blog james ci sono le tracce di sangue
giusta fare quello che vada messo qua
per fare colori non so neanche che cosa
sia il generatore di merda fantastico
anno snelli liquid c'è un liquido che fa
uno strano odore ok quindi non filo ai
polsi ste cagate qua il fila cielo
snelli liquid c'è un peso qua potevo
usare questo invece no voi io sto gioco
non lo capiscono gioco sia preso di come
sarà altra roba ci ho preso una roba
strana perde
le tracce di sangue che va bene non l'ho
capita vanno avanti c'è ancora quel
ragno ne va tutto a posto tutto bene
perfetto
beh almeno l'allegro dove trovare uno
degli oggetti per aprirla villa parti
che c'è una torcia guarda per aprire il
corso della ventilazione che ha come
proprio una cosa che volevo fare qualche
coincidenza incredibile
salve vada a sinistra c'è la sua detto
no bravo entra e la porta entra e la
porta non entra però devo andare per
forza di latte sfiga devo quindi
immagino che io debba fare stack agata
per trovare l'oggetto per aprire la
ventola prima che il ragno chi prenda
cioè senza farli vedere la mente ok
almeno sai cantare tipo achille lauro
madonna regate ansia ciò che devo
passare da un banco all'altro e nella
stessa ansia che vo quando copiavo nelle
verifiche
lo sai che fai schifo te l'ha mai detto
qualcuno lo dico io
forse è meglio non insultare certa gente
che magari sono un po permalosi ci sta e
perché ma basta cantare non sei capace
che fastidio madonna regala fatto un
casino per arrivare qua ci voglio
veramente me ne vado sto mettendo 6 ora
pare sta cosa dio mio
[Musica]
bravo a posto raga dovrei esserci
praticamente riuscito faccio fare
l'ultimo giro ma teoricamente ci siamo
ma dove su due ore uno slalom orribile
signori proprio lui volevo farmi tutto
all indietro tra l'altro modo ci penso
mi metti un check point per favore che
non me lo voglio rifare sto casino de
mettimi un check point a caso per favore
1 se muoio qua ma io devo rifarmi tutto
quindi dami un checkpoint c'è poi o
perfetto modo tornare tutto indietro dai
cheppallle veramente bambino salvato la
partita
una donna la mia potevano non farla la
mia ombra il suo gioco ma torna è
bruttissimo tutto va in giro da chi la
tua ombra e bruttino so che è normale
però porca vacca demonio porco
mi sono cagato addosso non me
l'aspettavo ma i cori
però c'è vero vale come si in pausa non
ce l'avrei mai fatta fatto un giro
strano teoricamente deve essere dietro
di me quindi tutto a posto
[Musica]
un cristo vai vai vai veloce in questo
casino devo arrivare alla ventola
porca vacca quanto letto e lentissimo
che avrà finito fitto ha finito non c'è
più a posto
madonna rega bruttissimo vai vai vai vai
vai questo è successo qua ci ha pisciato
qualcuno esce anche prima st chiazza per
terra vedi se ne frega dai apre tutto
sto casino che eccola per trovare che ti
la mia tipa che come fa ad essere in un
condotto d'areazione non sa solo lei
però vabbè che devo per forza scendere
va beh l'amore ho sentito che cantavi
proveniva da qua stai bene
perfetto ma questo era il cameraman io
che guardo sanremo secondo impiccato lui
c'è quindi ha poi dato vita alla pala
c'è che non verrebbe giunti qui in un
secondo gioco sono fatte di titanio come
possibile dai apriamo la porta poter
riuscire potevi andare via
no perché non volevi andare via non
capisco sarà mica perchè c'è un ragno
che bello estate ostia lido proprio qui
devo andare in giro per i piani a
cercare questi pezzi da inficiare dentro
la porta tipo questo ok va bene si può
fare ragazzi si può fare cos'è
pizzolotto smile position ma che cazzo
ci ho fatta show ho fatto due ore e
mezza e quindi eccolo a posto
lo trovai quindi avevo fatto a non ho
c'è ancora uno ma dai ma dai
c'erano tre porco demonio aveva l'ultimo
sarà penso da un'altra pace ci saranno
altre porte c'è di pò di qua io ho
trovato una chiave del secondo piano che
non ho neanche visto dovessero secondo
piano ecco ci sono schiave prost va bene
secondo piano manca l'ultimo pezzo raga
teoricamente poi dovrei aver fatto la
chiave questa non la dai subito tipo
qualcosa mi dice che non sa raisi 6 2 5
vediamo ma [ __ ] va ma [ __ ]
to sorella morta a pagare ragazzi ma o
migliore al mondo gioco con gli spaventi
più congegnati in assoluto cioè fatto
benissimo
non me l'aspettavo mai un job seeker mai
proprio [ __ ] a mi chiamo me
l'aspettavo mai veramente trimenti un
input di te li aspetti ma neanche per
sbaglio
chi è il genio che ha inventato sta roba
veramente ha fatto benissimo ma è
comunque ottimo de micheli nasconde
adesso scendo le scale però che non sa
piace delle scale demonio che devo fare
niente da una lucina
ok l'importante è essere riusciti a
scamparla ma antonio che contava i
quadri con pirla invece non era la pole
cose dietro
beh figo però l'ultimo pezzo grazie
molto gentile
ho dovuto rimettere tutti va bene perché
sono morto degli occhiali cosa cosa sto
vede cosa succede vi permettono di
vedere delle robe
quindi o secoli impronta e lo vedo che
era andato di qua dove avevo capito
anche prima che c'era qualcosa di strano
e sto coso visto buco ma e ronco ed il
tutto a posto non lo guarderò più dallo
spioncino adesso apre le porte e basta
[Musica]
achille lauro salve ma come mai sono
tutti ma cos'è punto cioè non lo so
veramente da marcolini qua porco demonio
vieni qua no ragazzi sono ragnatele
fermi ci sono regna tele non va bene ci
sono ragni a te cos'è ma perché chi
pronuncia la mia tipa che problemi cha
che problemi a lei statali di frank lo
vedo sento
immagino che io debba puntare quale a
fare tutto quanto in un punto oppure
sulla porta a minchia proprio devo
trovare l'unico punto dove dove si
possono puntare tutti quanti scommetto
ma porca di quella ladra [ __ ] porca
io ragazzi ve lo dico anno devo puntarli
dove non si scorge l'immagine quindi
forze su quel modo lì c'è un affare
pulsantoni bio cis comico shot cisco
vinchi no no no no no e quindi devo
combattere lei aiuto non la vedo
no ragazzi non la vedo eccole per terra
ha colpito dopo il pit
ha vinto a posto ho fatto check e anzi è
un posto giocasse robe comunque ve lo
dico dai dai manca ancora un giro ce la
fai fare tutto ciò che hai fatto
ho fatto fatto vinto sono forte a posto
tutto fuoco o bellissimo questo volevo
vedere come quando vedono ragni in casa
stessa cosa posso andare avanti tutto ok
grazie kg a porta chi la porta non si
chiude fa niente
questo è un bel lieto fine beh ragazzi
che provavo mesi episodi di paranormal
racchia k anche se effettivamente sempre
molto ansiolitico ma bello discrete a
creare schiacciate il tasto mi piace se
vi è piaciuto il video ragazzi al campo
alle lineari vallette aggiornati sui
nuovi video che escono e noi come sempre
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo vita della
ragazza
[Musica]